when it's time to get a whip there's a
place over the Great Lakes horizon with
water water everywhere but not a drop to
drink a place or the imminent danger of
its soaring murder it is second only to
that of its tap water
a place where tremors resulting from
mass arson fires remind of one your
hometown hero Michael Moore's to walk
these streets before he abandoned you
years ago where an economy once
propelled by the heart of the American
automotive industry is now driven
entirely by heroin and crack cocaine and
while the rest of the world tries to
import the beautiful fresh waters from
the Great Lakes in their backyard the
people of Flint prefer to harken back to
a simpler time
were they ladle their wood unfiltered on
chlorinated from their very own river a
place where residents appreciate a
frozen moment in time so they can sit
back enjoy a cold sip reflect with loved
ones and feel the slow onset arsenic
poison coursing through their veins and
as the light begins to fade and their
life flashes before their eyes they take
the scenic route examine the poor life
choices that brought them to the living
hell that is Flint as that last
refreshing sip they'll ever get to save
hits their palate for a taste
[Music]
what's that sound it's the sound of you
subscribing otherwise I'm going to send
anthrax to your house there's a button
below or you can click my face to go to
la door with credit comm or click one of
the videos playing next to me I think
there might be a mystery box what could
it be
anthrax